de vuelta Al Punto de partida frente al
parlamento sueco con el tradicional
birrete de graduación greta zamberg
organizó su última huelga escolar por el
clima
vamos a seguir protestando todos los
viernes porque esto es solo el principio
de la lucha
sanber comenzó su huelga climática aquí
frente al edificio del parlamento en
2018 a la edad de 15 años animando a los
estudiantes a faltar a clase los viernes
para exigir medidas contra el cambio
climático se convirtió en el rostro de
un movimiento global de París a Berlín
encabezó marchas en capitales europeas y
en 2019 se embarcó en un viaje de 15
días hacia nueva
el debate está cambiando y siento que la
gente se está tomando esto con más
urgencia y la gente está empezando a
concienciarse poco a poco y por eso lo
estoy haciendo Y sé que necesitamos que
lo haga el mayor número posible
al asistir a una cumbre de acción
climática de la ONU en Nueva York por
anunció un apasionado discurso
reprendiendo a los líderes mundiales
diciendo que no estaban haciendo lo
suficiente
me robaron mis sueños y mi infancia con
sus palabras vacías estamos al principio
de una extinción masiva y solo hablan de
dinero y de cuentos de hadas de
crecimiento económico eterno Cómo se
atreven
pero su activismo no ha estado exento de
reacciones en el punto de mira de los
escépticos del clima que intentan
socavar su mensaje incluidos Donald
Trump y Vladimir Putin desde el inicio
de su movimiento millones de estudiantes
en más de 180 países han participado en
las huelgas